До другого туру виборів - лічені дні.
Тут, у Глухові, за менше ніж 20 кілометрів від кордону з Росією,
жарти кандидата в президенти та коміка Володимира Зеленського
військових не веселять, а заяви - лякають.
Наразі ми лише чули, щоб зупинити війну,
потрібно просто перестати стріляти.
Нібито так звучить, що...
агресор, він такий - не веде бойових дій,
А українська армія лише стріляє…
і лише це провокує війну.
Якщо зробити висновок.
Він же більше нічого не каже.
У зоні проведення Операції об'єднаних сил на Донбасі
у першому турі перемогу здобув Володимир Зеленський.
Він обігнав чинного президента Петра Порошенка
у більшості з 79 спецдільниць.
Для трьох військових та бойових друзів це була несподіванка.
Настрої? Не райдужні...
Байду та Михайла із Запоріжжя, Авера з Києва
об'єднують не лише політичні погляди, але й спільний воєнний досвід.
Воювати на Схід пішли добровольцями в 2014 році.
За п’ять років служили в місцях найзапекліших боїв,
поховали чимало побратимів.
Військові не з чуток знають про становлення української армії.
Згадують, якщо на початку війни усе - від патронів до нижньої білизни -
закуповували волонтери, то тепер - держава.
За такі зміни і підтримують чинного президента.
Для того, щоб обрати Петра Порошенка вдруге,
покращення матеріального забезпечення армії замало.
Так вважає ветеран АТО Андрій Рева.
На війні він був від початку: спершу як волонтер, потім як боєць батальйону ”Айдар”.
Брав участь у оборонних боях в Щасті та Станиці-Луганській.
Тепер у мирному Києві працює в ІТ cфері.
Європейська ментальність, це коли карманич країни
причетний до корупції, наробив кучу негарних справ,
і його просто треба змінити,
і небо від цього не впаде.
Все, якось так. Тому для мене
не обрати Порошенка - це європейський вибір в першу чергу.
Якби замість Зеленського був інший, Вакарчук,
Костельман, хтось з молодих незапам'ятних бізнесменів,
який досягнув би
певної критичної маси підтримки народу,
я б голосував за нього.
Засуджує президента і за те, що й досі жоден генерал
не поніс відповідальність за службове недбальство.
Наприклад, за збиття влітку 2014 року військового літака ІЛ-76.
Тоді попри повідомлення СБУ щодо можливих атак,
генерал Назаров дав дозвіл на виліт.
Загинули 49 військових.
І хоч генерал судом був визнаний винним,
він і досі залишається на посаді і не позбавлений військових звань.
Те, що голосування на спецдільницях схоже на загальну картину по Україні -
добрий знак, каже колишній військовий-контрактник Тарас Чмут.
Адже це означає, що адміністративного тиску на військовослужбовців не було.
Окрім того, в зоні проведення операції об'єднаних сил
перебувають не лише Збройні Сили, але і Нацгвардійці, Нацполіція,
працівники СБУ та Держслужби з надзвичайних ситуацій.
Дехто з них міг через реформи останніх років позбувся посад та звання,
тож, можливо, ображений на чинну владу, каже військовий експерт.
Армія - це і є теж саме суспільство, тільки в мініатюрі.
Зараз як не як є стабільність, коли один і той самий міністр,
коли начальник Генштабу той самий,
одна і та сама кадрова офіцерська...
офіцерський прошарок, який багато років веде реформу.
. Успішну чи ні - вже інше питання,
але всі знають, чого від них очікувати.
Серед повноважень президента - зміна начальника Генштабу.
Кого на цю посаду призначить у разі перемоги Володимир Зеленський,
досі невідомо. Його мовчання лише збільшує побоювання військових у Глухові.
Та в будь-якому разі, вони усвідомлюють своє право
чинити опір в разі злочинних наказів.
Ми не даємо присягу президенту,
так само, як  і не даємо присягу державі,
ми даємо присягу українському народу.
І ми її вже давали, присяга дається один раз.
Він як верховний головнокомандувач,
звісно, буде віддавати якісь накази.
Але є таке поняття як злочинний наказ,
який кожен з нас має право не виконувати.
Прихильники Зеленського заспокоюють, що антидержавні
чи антиєвропейські кроки будь-якого президента
суспільство контролюватиме. Наразі головне,
аби вибори пройшли прозоро.